The Gulf War ended 30 years ago, and the Iraq
War ended a decade ago, yet the Congressional
authorizations for both wars remain on the
books. It's welcome news that Congress is
looking to repeal these outdated measures. However
some, like Bernie Sanders, want to go further and
propose a new War Powers Act that assumes that
only Congress has the authority to send American
troops into combat. This Congressional overreach
threatens the Constitution's architecture,
which envisioned an executive capable of acting
decisively to protect the country, its citizens,
and its rights under international law. It's
no surprise that as American security concerns
and obligations have grown, so to the president's
writ. But it is also Congress's job to push back
against presidents who now claim a right to engage
in hostilities to protect some undefined notion of
national interest. There is no more important
decision than putting US troops in harm's way.
Hence, fully understanding each branch's unique
role in that decision is no less important
today than it was in 1787. Should Congress
amend the War Powers Act? And if so, how?
Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.